[Music]
sorry okay not not at this time no
because you showed up to a a public
Courthouse
intoxicated okay that's public
intoxication that is
uh chargeing in Oklahoma
statutes
okay so have you had anything to drink
today have you had stuff to drink today
yes
no I'm sorry what have you had anything
to drink today yes I CL one morning yes
this morning
yes
like like an hour ago this
morning no this morning Kimberly ask to
see your attor stop
talking I'm sorry what you have the
right to stop talking my my RO
gentlem she has the right to refuse to
answer
questions so goad and come with
me we going
have if you have the order glass eyes
slge spee
Swain I can go home with my husband he's
going to take me out no you're you're
going to come with me now you're going
to be Republic
intoxication I don't understand you're
in public you're intoxicated you're
going to go to jail is what he's telling
you
I but I haven't done anything I don't I
don't I don't understand you're
intoxicated at this point ma'am you you
are drunk you have you have slur speech
okay you're very unsteady on your feet
okay I can smell the order of alcohol on
your breath as you're talking to me I
can smell
it okay we noticed it at the front door
when you came
in well my husband's I can take I can go
home please just let me go home that's
it's on how Works
ma'am come on you are being recorded
again come
on I'm sorry
gentlemen I I don't understand I don't
understand I'm I'm so
sorry you have anything else on your
person that you like for your husband to
take like a cell phone keys or anything
I don't understand I okay I'm sorry
could could you you just tell me what's
going on okay you're being under arrest
for public
intoxication okay we we noticed we saw
saw that you were unsteady on your feet
downstairs okay we watched you come up
the stairs as you were coming to court
but we going to get the elevator okay
you're very unsteady coming up the
stairs okay we also have the doc
gentleman that was in the room with you
that he could smell the order of alcohol
coming from your breath as I was talking
to you downstairs here I could also
smell the order of alcohol upon my
bre okay and even while you're talking
your speech is very
slurred go back around to the front
desk okay oh going this
way I was just wondering if my
husband home no
canone down seat on those gr chairs
right
there okay there's nothing else on your
person no earrings or
anything get your paper from
you and what's your first
name you got your Nik buddy
how's it
going have you already
Wing right Wings is out
Alle I see her
sure miss coach go ahead and stand up
for
me Palms together thumbs
up
not all
the you got to pick your ble
[Music]
right
good so we're going to go ahead and go
through this door right
here okay in between those two doors
right there and your left just stand
right there for
him
so that's that's what we're going to
jail you got theide
more okay it's first door on your
left okay go step
through okay first door on your right
keep
going back
go ahead and step in there and have a
seat on the bench to your right good
yeah goad slide down to the end over
here for
me your
hands are your wrist up
all right let me see right
wrist good down down there you
go the brown Pap set next to the toilet
huh what that's where she got
yeah